thanks Ron can everyone hear me so I'm
going to talk about fully homomorphic MS
Academy proofs and this is in joint work
with a poor wah
Yale was here and Anna so due to current
advancements in technology you know many
a times the traditional crypto
primitives are no longer sufficient to
meet the current a security months right
and one way to overcome this problem is
to augment the known crypto primitives
with additional properties and one such
property considered in the crypto
literature is home morphism and home
office amidst is best explained using
the notion of fully homomorphic
encryption this remarkable notion allows
you to combine many cipher text into a
resulting ciphertext of of a message
that is a function of the original
messages so this was a remarkable notion
and has tremendous applications in
cryptography and home office on was not
just added in the context of encryption
there have been other primitives as well
for instance home office Sam has been
traded in the context of signatures
it was also been stated in the context
of secret sharing and the list goes on
so this workshop is about proofs right
so a natural question to ask is can you
combine home morphism and proof systems
and in order for this combination to
even make sense we are going to focus on
non interactive proof system
so before I formally define what this
means let's just look at an intuitive
definition of fully homomorphic proof so
intuitively what we want is we should be
able to combine many proofs on many
instances you know into a proof on some
instance that is a function on the
original instances and the two natural
properties we want is that if you start
with a proofs on yes instances and
suppose I say these are proofs that are
accepted by the verifier and suppose let
us say the resulting instance is also a
yes instance then you want the guarantee
that this proof is also accepted by the
verify okay so this is the correctness
guarantee and the sound as guarantee
says that you know it doesn't matter
what proofs you start with maybe these
instances are yes instances right if you
result in a no instance then the proof
should be rejected by the verify so I'm
going to formalize what this means in a
second so as you have seen in this
workshop just correctness and soundness
in a proof system alone doesn't suffice
you know there are two directions we can
take either we can take the sickness
direction or the privacy direction
stressing this here talks about you know
the proof length being much smaller than
the witness size right and privacy
somehow guarantees that the proof hides
the witness you know what Heights means
can be formalized in many ways and in
this work we are going to take this
privacy direction okay we are going to
propose to notions of fully homomorphic
Nezzer can we prove and we are going to
give constructions for both these
notions
so why is this notion yeah
it'll be long yeah okay so why why study
this notion no my wife works in a
consulting firm and her day-to-day job
is to collect medical data from
different research groups and these
research groups inter and generate these
medical data from many sources right and
their job is to come up with a model
that sort of fits this medical data and
then they sell this model to clients you
know for instance pharmaceutical
companies there are incentives for
different entities in this system to lie
you know maybe the consulting firm
promised the pharmaceutical company that
you know they're going to deliver some
model in some period of time and then
later realize that they couldn't do it
maybe they now generate a fake model to
convince the pharmaceutical company how
big because they don't want to lose a
repetition so in this case we want to we
want to impose a system where these
entities don't like and one way to do
this is to make these different entities
prove whatever they're doing so for
every outcome they need to publish a
proof that that they have followed
certain procedures
and here itself we can see that you know
you need some form of home Orphic proofs
right because you know these consulting
firms just don't talk to one research
group you know they talk to many groups
so they receive money proofs so somehow
they should be able to combine these
different proofs together to publish one
proof and you also want some privacy
guarantees because you know you don't
want the proof given by the consulting
firm to this company do not reveal
information about how this model was
generated
so low let's look at what it means for a
proof system to be fully homomorphic and
satisfied zero knowledge property
so in order to define the proof system
first I need to define the relation okay
and the relation we are going to
consider is this relation where every
instance in this relation R consists of
two parts the first part is a circuit
and the second part is a bit and a
witness W belongs to this relation if
the output of the circuit on this
witness is this bit B and as you can see
that this captures np-complete languages
and the reason why we consider this
relation is because it has some natural
composability property if you combine
many instances in the language
corresponding to this relation then you
will end up with an instance that also
belongs to the language you know for
instance in this example suppose I say
you have C 1 B 1 2 through C and B N and
suppose I say you want to compose them
using some circuit see one way to do it
is just to augment this circuit C on top
of all these circuits right and so now
the witness for the final instance is
just a concatenation of the original
witnesses
hey is this clear okay so what are the
algorithms associated with this proof
system as in a zero knowledge proof
system you have the set up algorithm
that outputs a common different string
and there's a prove algorithm that
outputs a proof for some instance and
eval algorithm which is different from
the existing approved systems takes as
input a CRS it also takes us input the
circuit that we are using to compose in
addition you will take as input
different proofs on different instances
and then there's a Valga rhythm outputs
a proof on the home Oracle evaluated
instance and C star is obtained by
composing C with the circuits c1 through
CM and finally you have the verification
algorithm okay so let me describe how
these algorithms are evaluated yeah yeah
this is an instance yeah
okay so I'm just going to pictorially
they note how these algorithms work so
now we have the setup algorithm that
generates a common reference string and
this common reference string is given to
different parties who generate proofs on
many instances right and then there is a
public home Orphic evaluation algorithm
that takes us and put these different
pros and our different instances gets
the final proof and then the
verification algorithm outputs exact
origin okay so again what are the
properties we need it's the same as
before right so we want that as long as
the original proofs were acceptable by
the verifier then you want the new proof
should also be accepted by the verifier
and similarly we want the property that
you know if if an instance is in no
instance then there should be rejected
by that so it should be another bit be
here it's a typo
so in this case that won't happen if
you're combining yes instances will
always end up with a substance okay so
what about privacy guarantee so the
intuitive privacy guarantee want is that
if the original proofs are 0 noise
proofs and the resulting evaluated proof
should also be a zero knowledge proof
and we are going to satisfy this by
defining this notion of unlink ability
so what does unlink ability say the
sunna community says that if I generate
a fresh proof on the instance C star
comma C of B 1 through B n right using
the using the witnesses W 1 through W
this should be indistinguishable from a
home Orphic evaluated proof on the same
instance
so and this notion is inspired by the
notion of randomized about flow systems
no it won't be so in the NRK as the
fresh proof will also grow with the
instance sighs I mean the once you
evaluate the proof it will just grow
with the instance size so in particular
structure of the circuit is not being
hidden right yeah yeah exactly right
because this circuit is also big circuit
its obtained by yeah
this is a security property on top like
on top of like the naive thing that you
and water is this like part of your face
or I'm going to get back to that in a
second yeah let's say the initial
circuits were some kind of universal
circuit because the structure as a
midpoint it is not hidden star is a
bigger Universal circuit so the bigger
circuit is like a bunch of universal
circuit put together so it will be a
bunch of circuits on top of it another
circuit that you are composing so right
so yeah so I'm just denoting this
pictorially so whether you evaluate this
you think the underlying proofs or you
turned into proof after I should not be
able to distinguish so why is unlink
ability useful coming back to alex
question so if you combine a link
ability with the standard notion of zero
knowledge then you get this ideal
privacy guarantee that we stated earlier
the proof is is really simple you know
using a link ability you can switch the
evaluated proof to the fresh proof right
and now what does zero now I say says
that the proof is zero noise so you can
switch the fresh proof to simulated
proof
this doesn't satisfy some sickness by
the way this doesn't satisfy so
synchronize I don't want to comment on
their construction because it's in
different setting yeah but you don't a
guarantee on link ability it's not just
about composition you also need to
randomize because you want to hide the
fact that you actually compost but we
can we can talk offline okay
another interesting yeah if you start to
is like zero intrusion you have is you
have a link ability you get your
knowledge for them yeah yeah but you
were just like forget about nothing
kabillion just requires your knowledge
for everything right definition becomes
a little clumsy so what you're
essentially saying is that there should
be you need to come up with a simulator
that takes as input simulator proofs and
output another simulator proof that is
indistinguishable morphing proof doesn't
reveal
so this unlink abilities is useful much
more than getting zero noise for the
evaluated proof and as I'm going to talk
about now so for instance if you combine
and link ability with single hop
evaluation you also get multi-hop
evaluation so and the proof is also very
simple so suppose let's say you do have
a proof that you obtained by composing
evaluating many proofs right and now
this proof looks like a fresh proof
final ink ability property so now we can
combine it with more other fresh proofs
and get again home Orphic evaluate these
proofs to get another evaluated proof
and so on so you can keep on recursively
doing this yeah if I treat them as like
no empty witnesses and just run a fresh
proof system only then the size keeps
growing I mean we still want that it's
polynomial in the instance side right
like if what you're suggesting it will
grow very fast I should be able to do
this how many of our times a1 right like
any polynomial yeah
yes I can get a constant yeah in this
case and and also it won't it won't
satisfy the unlink of already a
definition as well could it like the
maximum like push size of a circuit of
the size that you're talking about right
there yeah but do this thing and blow up
like additively or not right I think
you're something that you yeah you can't
do that but in our case you don't even
have any blow up like we can achieve one
bit more cuz then you'll have one one
eventually
okay well I'm allowed to grow in a
circuit size right with a big gate if
you think about they get by gating
before every game they pay penalty of
one additional beat that I can be and
what will look like fresh we can set
what's I can said the first thing to be
lonely again
whatever is suggesting will only go till
some bounded number of evaluations right
that's it like so in my case I can go to
any unborn a number of evaluations so in
your case you need to fix a priority the
bound and then the parameters will grow
with the one in in my case in something
yeah
okay so these are the properties we need
I mean complete correctness soundness
and you don't always generally ability
so you need zero knowledge in addition
to unlink ability for for us to get
privacy okay so the the definition of
home Orphic newbie proofs is identical
except that there won't be any setup no
we just have the algorithms approval and
and in terms of completeness honest and
a link of redefinitions it's the same as
before
now you additionally also have the
witness indistinguishability guarantee
which just says that if you compute the
proof with respect to one witness or
with respect to a different witness for
the same instance you should not be able
to tell apart so let me state our
results so the unlink ability says that
if you mean a link abilities ax says
that it should be in description from a
fresh proof so now if you combine it
with Wi you get like so we show that
there exists fully homomorphic metrics
for NP in the common random string model
we get our results in a common random
stream model based on decision linear
assumption in and by image
so what is this assumption I mean this
assumption has been fairly studied in
the by linear maps community so you it's
a symmetric group so you define a
bilinear map on on the same group and
then you have a different target group
you know suppose let's say the order of
you want the order of both the groups to
be in the same prime P and then the
Assumption states are following so
suppose let's say give you the generator
of the group and I give you G to the X
to the Y is e to the X AG to the Y P
then you should not be able to given
these this information you should not be
able to tell apart G to the a plus B
versus T to the our where our respect
afresh independent of all other values
yeah so we also show how to get fully
amorphic movies for NP in the plane
model as I said earlier there's no setup
based on some falsifiable assumption on
a linear maps I won't be describing this
assumption but let me just give you a
flavor of how this assumption looks like
so it will essentially be dealing with
some auxiliary information and this
auxiliary information will be some
constant number of group elements whose
export exponents will depend on these
values X Y a B and R we don't know the
answer to that question oh that I can
explain but once I give the overview
explain yeah okay so in terms of related
works both rated books have mostly
focused on the case when you're only
home Oracle evaluating a single instance
and proof where and moreover even in
this regime or this regime is called
malleable proof systems even in this
regime they've either focused on
restricted class of relations in which
case they show how to get such proof
system so I'm binding your maps or they
can actually get it for general
relations from knowledge assumptions or
you can even get gender relations but
homeworkfilms a secret state meaning
that the evaluator has to have some
secret information associated with the
original proofs even this we can do so
for the home orphism case itself where
you know your home Oracle evaluating
multiple instances we know very
restricted class of we know results only
for a suited class of relations you have
a question yeah
all of them yeah it will grow with the
instance size in our case it will grow
with the circuit sighs I mean Multi hope
the instance size also grows so
correspondingly yeah so once you
evaluate you're not getting rid of the
original circuits I mean you're going to
keep this
so as some of your questions have
alluded to there have been like lot of
books in terms of homework we're
evaluating searching proofs under the
umbrella of incremental proof systems
this was first proposed by valiant and
what does our work say about so sickness
nothing so we don't achieve the sickness
but even achieving privacy
alone seems very challenging so and in
general there are techniques to
generically combine music proofs and
assessing proofs in order to get the
best of both worlds and we hope that our
work will be a starting point to in this
direction we want okay yeah
we randomized
it's possible if you don't care about
assumptions and it
okay so let's dive into the construction
how much time do I have
darlink ability property says that you
don't know whether you you are composed
or not yeah say in violence case like
kind of knowing how deep you are it's
pretty important because you know when
to stop your instructor when you go back
if you didn't know whether you're fresh
or not then you don't know how much to
extract into the class okay so we can
take the discussion offline okay so let
me give an overview for our construction
so the starting point or construction is
there is a construction based on dealin
by yens raffia namitha so I'm going to
stick with the same relation as before
so let me just briefly describe how the
proof system their proof system looks
like so the goal is to prove that some
instance CB belongs as language so the
circuit looks there's suppose I say the
circuit looks like this and then you
have a business here and there's a bit
that's the output of the circuit on this
witness so the first step is to evaluate
this circuit so you have this
intermediate values so the next step is
to commit to the intermediate values as
well as the witness and you also commit
to the output wire and the parameters
associated with the commitment scheme
I'm going to use the word parameters a
lot from now on these parameters will be
in the CRS
so and moreover note that the commitment
for the final output wire is computed
using randomness zero this is to enable
the verifier to check if the output was
zero okay so the next step is to show
that these values are indeed zero or one
you know
and finally they show proofs of
consistencies you want to make sure that
the values committed here are consistent
that is w5 is obtained by a nine dog w1
and w2 for instance
so you have three consistency proofs so
I'm going to call the proofs where you
prove that the computed values are zero
one has a bit proofs and the proof
proves that that proved the consistency
of the computed values has great truth
so natural question to ask is can their
proofs be made fully homomorphic Nasik
proofs you know and the way you would do
it is to add a home or evaluation
algorithm a natural way to add homework
correlation algorithm is suppose let's
say you have two instances right so you
have these commitments right so suppose
let's say you want to join them with
some 98 right so what you do is you
evaluate nine of B 1 B 2 and then you
commit to it using the same parameters
of course and then you also need to
compute a K proof right
of course this is not secure because
remember I said that these commitments
are actually commitments with respect to
randomness zero right so you no longer
can afford to leak information about
these values because they are now
intermediate wires so what you do is you
realign demise these commitments you
know and rerun devising these
commitments have other challenges
because you also need to Maul the proofs
associated with these commitments and so
on
so our technical contribution here is to
show how to carry out this approach now
you want to randomize the commitments
and show how to modify the proofs
accordingly so this was a simple
modification of the Ostrovsky's ie
construction so the next step is going
to be more challenging which is to
construct fully homomorphic nary proofs
to do that let me just briefly recall
how the Navy proof system looks like
so there newbie proof system is a
modification of the nesic pro system
where now note that there is no
parameter in the CRS anymore right so
there's no Sierras so the prover has to
generate the parameters right so I'm
going to make him generate two
parameters and what is the point of
making him generate two parameters they
have these two very nice properties that
one of these two parameters has to be
binding and the other has to be hiding
so one of these parameters has to be
binding the other will correspondingly
be hiding and moreover these binding and
hiding parameters will be
indistinguishable and roughly we are
going to use hiding to ensure witness
indistinguishability and binding to
ensure sounds
okay so the proof structure is is almost
the same as before except that instead
of generating just one commitment per
wire we're going to generate two
commitments and these two commitments
will be with respect to these two
parameters and you still prove
consistency for all three commitments
you know this green commitment will be
with respect to green commits
sorry green proof will be with respect
to green commitments and the blue proof
will be with respect to the blue
commitments
okay so I'm going to skip the WI prove
their proof so a natural question to ask
is if you can extend again newbee proves
to a fetch maybe proofs right and this
step turns out to be very challenging
and the reason is because you know
there's one prover who computes this
proof with respect to his own pair of
parameters right and there's another
provoke imputed on a different instance
with respect to his own pair of
parameters so now how do you join these
two proofs together now because they are
computed with respect to these different
parameters so that's the first issue we
somehow have to make sure that you know
these commitments computed with respect
to different parameters interact with
each other and the second issue is
unlink ability you know if a fresh proof
we're to be constructed then the prover
is going to only going to use two
parameters for the whole proof right but
if you join both these proofs together
then you'll be left with four parameters
instead of just two right note that this
problem didn't exist in the music
construction because the parameter
there's only one parameter and that was
in the Sierras
okay so the new idea is to the new idea
is to actually have two parameters for
every gate in the circuit so we're going
to have binding hiding parameter for
every gate in the circuit and then we
are going to make the prover commit to
the bit value with respect to both these
parameters so suppose let's say during
the evaluation of the circuit though the
wire value was B once and then you're
going to commit with respect to P P 1
and P P 2 here and similarly here if the
output of the NAND gate was bit we are
going to make him commit to PP 3 commit
to this value using both P P 3 and P
before
okay but now how do these commitments
interact with these parameters you know
associated with this gate because you
know these these words to go into this
gate so somehow we have to make them
compatible and one way to make the
compatible is just to make the prover
also commit to be one using these two
parameters associated with this gate so
now with respect to every wire you're
left with four commitments right this
obviously read leads to one important
challenge which is that how do you
ensure that whatever commitments the the
adversarial proven has given contains
the same value for all you know he could
be cheating here right so this is going
to be the technical contribution of this
construction so what we show is we
somehow show how to have four
commitments and we are going to have
four proofs
between all these commitments in such a
way that proves consistency across the
commitments between any pair of indices
yeah and the reason why we do this is
that you know this automatically gives
the sourness you know because one of the
pair of parameters has to be binding
recall that this was the property
guaranteed by the GI scheme here also
one of the parameters has to be binding
right
in which case there has to be some line
in which case both the vertices on this
line have to correspond to binding
parameters right which will ensure that
the value committed to along that line
is the same so this will automatically
guarantee soundness the witness
indistinguishability is going to be
tricky because if you go back to us
prove the way they prove witness
indestructibility is arguing for hiding
and binding parameter separately but the
problem here is that these proofs are
going to be intertwined so it's it's
unclear how would you switch from one
witness to another witness here so I'm
not going to be I'm not gonna have time
to describe the details of this
construction so if you're interested I
can sample fresh CRS is sort of going to
be non black box and underlined like
it's going to take a very few unrolled
it as a circuit and good so there's no
news no CRS here but I mean like the
underlying CR Latif IPC something on
that this year so the other waifu's yeah
PI 1 5 PI 1 6 5 5 5 to 6 yeah going to
be non black box in the verification
algorithm of the underlying
don't quite understand your question but
I can talk to you offline about it yeah
okay so so let me conclude so we define
fully homomorphic proofs we showed how
to construct fully morphic knees extend
Denise from assumptions on by linear
maps and for the affection is a
construction we give a new way of
randomizing and modeling
proof system TOS pro systems and finally
we show how to we give a new proof
technique that
proves that different commitments come
completed with respect to different
parameters have the same value and there
are some obvious open problems you know
basing efficient TVs on nona sumption
recall that our assumption was some
variant of deal and not deal in second
is lattice based efficient essex we have
lattice waves mystics now so can you
actually get home morphism as well and
other question is to combine succinct
Ness and fully homomorphic Nozick's and
finally are there other applications of
for mopping
[Applause]